- All right, before we go,
let me serve up one last story
that might bring you some joy.
This is "What I'm Liking."
(upbeat music)
(audience cheers)
A woman in Australia named Ingrid
is stepping up to rehabilitate
a neighborhood thief, even inviting him
to live in her home for good.
Here's the criminal's mugshot.
(audience laughs)
Yup.
Pirate Kitty Kylo as he's known
spent months stealing hundreds of items,
hundreds, from neighbors'
porches and yards.
Everything from gloves to shoes to toys.
(laughs) It's awesome.
His original owners posted
the goods on social media
for people to reclaim,
and while some thought it was adorable,
others not so much because they're no fun
'cause it's funny.
(audience laughs)
What's happening in your world
that you can't find that funny?
Anyway, they knew Pirate
Kitty needed some help,
so that's where Ingrid stepped in.
So we have her on the line
along with Pirate Kitty himself.
What's up, Ingrid?
(audience cheers)
- Hi, Kelly.
Hi, everybody.
- Oh my god, I love Pirate Kitty.
So explain how you ended up
taking care of Pirate Kitty.
- Well, not everybody
loves Pirate, you see.
And his owners were
getting a lot of complaints
to local council and they
had threats against him,
and so they decided that the
best thing that they could do
was to try and rehome him.
And that's how he came to me.
And so I volunteered to put
him into witness protection,
which is where you change his name,
you change his location, and help him
to become a quiet indoor kitty,
but the community was having none of it.
They just wanted to know where
he was, what he was doing,
and so I started posting
his information on socials.
- So, here is my thing.
If we could go back to that picture
with all that crap on that table.
(audience laughs)
Why are all these people not thanking him
for his service like a public service?
All this crap is just laying
out in peoples' yards?
(audience laughs)
Like I have a problem with
these people, not this cat.
This cat is trying to help us be clean.
That is just wrong.
Is he still a thief?
Does he steal stuff in your house?
- He definitely still is a thief.
Now, he's a fully indoor kitty
and his routine is the second
that the lights go out,
whatever is not nailed down in the house
gets stolen and taken up to the landing
outside our bedrooms,
which we call loot landing.
And every night we come out,
and there's more things out there.
There's toys, swishy sticks,
his favorite is a Elf on the Shelf,
and every morning when we get out of bed,
he's sitting there waiting for his photo
'cause he's so proud of what he's done.
My only regret, though,
is I bought him a very, very
noisy toy called a Floppy Fish,
which is one of those
battery operated fish
that jump up and down.
Great, except at 2:00
am it's extremely noisy,
but he's happy, and
that's all that matters.
- Yeah, my poor dog.
He has never had a noisy toy.
Yeah, and he shall never
'cause I don't wanna hear it
in my house (chuckles).
I'm like, "I'll play fetch
with you, I'll love on you,
you are not getting a noisy toy."
Thank you so much, Ingrid.
I love that he's such a helper
and he's trying to clean
up the neighborhood
is what he was doing.
I'm liking your post right now, all right?
(audience applauds)
And that's not all, ma'am,
our season long partner,
Pilot Pin makers of G2,
the go-to pin of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
wanna honor ultimate
overachievers just like you
and a special park kitty
trying to clean up the world,
so they're gonna be writing
you a check for $1,000.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
Thank you so much, Ingrid!